Well I've said it before and I'll say it again,
everything's coming up mushrooms.
It's revolutionizing food,
and now, fashion.
PureWow reports that high fashion brand, "Hermes"
has designed its first bag made of mushroom leather.
That's right.
They're working with MycoWorks,
a company that uses Mycelium,
which is the roots of the mushroom,
to make alternative leather.
It looks like leather and it feels like leather,
but it's more eco-friendly
and it uses less water and energy to produce.
Wow.
(audience cheers and applauds)
This leather alternative
is coming to fashion, furniture
and even seats in your car,
so you can vroom vroom on your mushroom.
Oh that's cute.
Stella McCartney also just trademarked "Mylo"
and she'll be working exclusively with that material,
moving forward.
And so, I'm so grateful.
It is the future and here we are.
I love it, this is so positive.
(audience applauds)
I think it's fascinating.
I don't understand how it works, but I wanna know more.
All right, we got to, you know,
we love a taste test, here, at the desk,
and today, we got a big one.
It's a bold new snack.
Women's Health reports, model, Ashley Graham
says she's got the perfect surprising snack combination,
created by her two year old son.
Listen to this, it's spicy tortilla chips,
dipped in crunchy peanut butter.
(chuckles) Okay.
Sound good or no?
What do you think?
Well, we're gonna give it a taste, right here.
We have it right here.
Thank you, Drew.
Of course, my love.
Okay, so these are, this is a spicy chip.
These are spicy chips.
Okay.
All right.
And you're gonna dip it in the peanut butter.
I'm salivating.
Right.
(tortilla chips crunch)
I actually think this might be great.
Okay.
Florence.
We also have an audience member tasting.
Say hi Florence.
Florence Alice.
Florence, you got it too?
(audience applauds)
Hi.
All right, grab this chip.
Okay.
And dip it in the crunchy peanut butter.
Florence Alice.
I'm gonna take
a really spicy one.
Yeah. Good, all the...
I'm excited to hear what you think.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Give it a try.
I have so many thoughts.
It taste a lot of peanut butter.
(chuckles) Yeah.
And now it tastes a little spice.
It's not bad.
I thought it was gonna be ugh.
It's not bad, it's good.
Yeah.
What was that word again?
Was it "blugh"?
Yeah, blugh, blugh, blugh.
Yeah, mm-hm.
You're my kind of woman.
Mna, mna, mna.
I "mna, mna, mna" all the time.
Mm.
You know, what's it's giving me?
It's like when you have Thai food,
like a Pad Thai or something,
(Drew groans)
and there's peanuts in the spice.
You know what I'm talking about?
Right here.
Florence, okay.
How many stars do you give it?
Out of five.
I'll give it four.
I'm not a five star person.
I never give anybody five stars, sorry, but,
(audience chuckles)
four stars is good.
I mean, I would eat this.
Four stars from Florence.
I give it five.
I'm into it.
I do too,
I'm gonna go all five.
(bright theme music)